When newly elected
Congressman Ritchie Torres,
arrived in Washington in January,
his presence was already historic
as the first Afro-Latino
openly gay man elected
to the House of Representatives.
Fight for Trump!
But as it turned out,
the history making was
just getting started.
You'll never take back
our country with weakness.
You have to show strength.
We are following breaking
news, at this hour.
These are pro Trump supporters,
who have taken to the
steps of the Capitol.
I've never been more
overwhelmed in my life.
House resolution 24,
impeaching Donald John Trump.
The sheer range of issues,
that come before a member of Congress
and the complexity of those issues,
is unlike anything I've seen.
For Torres, the introduction was bracing,
but far from the first
challenge he's faced.
Raised in a housing project
and struggling with issues,
all too common among his
friends and neighbors.
He's risen to represent
the poorest congressional
district in the US.
With determination and independence.
I spoke to the congressmen
about how his journey
from poverty to the national stage
has shaped his unique
political perspective.
My story is the story of the Bronx.
It's a story of struggle,
but it's also one of overcoming.
Well Congressman Torres, thank
you so much for doing this.
Tell me just to start,
tell me a little bit about the beginning
because it so informs, how
you are doing this job.
Tell me about growing up
because it was not easy.
I was born and raised in the Bronx.
I spent almost all my life in poverty.
I was raised by a single mother,
who had to raise three
children on minimum wage.
I grew up in public housing
and what I remember above
all is the living conditions,
the conditions of mold and
mildew and leaks and lead.
The struggle to breathe in my own home.
You know, as a child, I was repeatedly,
in the hospital for asthma,
largely caused by housing
conditions like vermin and molds.
And I actually grew up
in a public housing development,
right across the street
from Trump golf course.
And while the government
was investing more
than a hundred million dollars
in a golf course for Donald Trump,
you know, I saw the
conditions in my own home,
get worse every single day.
And I remember asking myself at the time,
"what does it say about our society
that we're willing to
invest more in a golf course
than in the homes of
low-income black and brown New Yorkers?"
It was as if I was living
a tale of two cities.
And tell me about the Bronx.
I mean, what constitutes it?
What makes it what it is?
The Bronx is the comeback
County of New York.
During the 1970s, the
Bronx was plagued with
disinvestment and arson and abandonment.
And the people of the Bronx,
instead of leaving the city,
largely stood here.
And rebuilt and revitalized the Bronx.
The Bronx has its fair
share of challenges,
but we have some of the
most resilient people
you'll ever meet.
And the resilience of the
Bronx came to light powerfully,
during COVID-19.
It's the home of essential workers,
who put their lives at risk,
during the peak of the pandemic,
so that most of us could
safely shelter in place.
Resilience has been a through line
of Torres's life
and nowhere has that been more apparent,
than his battle with
depression and anxiety.
Bringing those struggles to the fore,
has turned him into a powerful advocate
for mental health awareness.
You've been very public
about your struggles
with your own mental health
and have drawn a lot
of accolades for that.
What convinced you that
you had this mission?
The experience of coming out as a gay man
inspired me to be open and honest,
about every aspect of my life,
including my struggles with depression.
I became the first, openly LGBTQ
elected official from the Bronx, in 2013.
But several years before then,
I was at the lowest point in my life.
I was struggling with depression.
I had dropped out of college.
I lost a close friend
to an opioid overdose.
There were moments when I
thought of taking my own life
because I felt as if the
world around me had collapsed
I felt a profound sense of failure.
And as a public figure,
I feel a particular sense of obligation
to be honest about my
struggles with mental illness.
You know, it's important
for people to know,
you know, I would not be alive today.
Were it not for the
power of mental health,
which saved my life.
The Bronx is populated with characters
and kindred spirits
committed to tackling systemic
injustices by working in
and leveraging the system.
If you know this better
than longtime politician
Jimmy Vacca,
who represented the borough
on the New York City Council
and served as a mentor to Ritchie Torres.
You know, one person and if
we can look at the first clip,
the Jimmy Vacca clip.
If you can hand that to the Congressman.
Without hurting anyone's
feelings in my profession,
many politicians are glad handers,
Ritchie is not.
Ritchie is a strategic policy type of wonk
who thinks of how to correct what's wrong,
from a legislative point of view,
from a policy point of view.
He was head of the
Investigations Committee
of the New York City Council.
And the last investigation
Ritchie conducted with his staff,
was finding out that the
head of the New York City
Police Department's, Human Rights Division
engaged in racism, homophobia,
and antisemitic remarks.
And that person is no longer
with the New York City Police Department.
Ritchie pursued that, Ritchie got answers,
Ritchie took action.
So Ritchie is persistent.
Ritchie knows exactly what he's doing
and when he's in the room,
there will be accountability.
So there's a lot to unpack there.
And I want to start with
Jimmy Vacca as a key figure,
It sounds like in your life.
I mean someone who you went to work for,
he identified you,
I believe when you were
a student volunteer
and it really did, you know
sort of set you on a path
to where you are today.
Tell me about the beginnings of that.
Well, with the exception of my mother,
Jimmy Vacca has been,
the most formative figure in my life.
Back in 2005, Jimmy was looking
for a young student to service
his district manager for a day.
So I met Jimmy, I spent a day with him,
interacting with constituents
and it was the first
time I could see myself,
as a public servant.
I enjoyed it, just the
time I spent with people,
listening to their problems,
figuring out how to solve those problems.
And after that encounter,
with Jimmy Vacca,
I set such a strong impression in him
that he eventually brought
me onto his campaign.
Vacca's encouragement and support
led Torres to quickly
broaden his portfolio,
putting him directly in charge
of solving complex and important
issues and finding success.
His ambition blossom to
stepping out on his own,
to seek public office,
his own seat on the City Council.
But there was a small problem
you don't normally associate
with aspiring politicians.
I'm new at this, forgive me.
In my early years in politics,
I found the experience of public speaking
to be so unnerving.
That I would have to
drink a glass of wine,
before delivering a speech
or before knocking on someone's door.
We're here to say no!
To creating separate and unequal schools
Over time, I became much
more accustomed to it
and you know, it's second nature to me.
But, I found the experience
of speaking in public
and the sheer amount of,
of retail politicking,
you know to be draining
for me as an introvert
to be anxiety inducing.
And yet, you kept with it.
What was it that, that made it worthwhile?
I felt the weight of leadership
and responsibility on my shoulders.
And that motivated me to
campaign my heart out.
I'm running because I want
to be part of a city council,
that gives everyday people a chance.
I was one of, nine candidates
when I first ran for the
City Council, back in 2013.
And very few people thought I would win.
But I won because I knocked
on thousands of doors
and people came to see
their hopes and dreams
for their children, embodied
in my candidacy and my story.
So, there are a number of people
who would be quite content
and have been more than content
to serve as a City Council member,
for the biggest and some would argue
the greatest city in
America, maybe the world.
And yet you make a decision
to take it a step further
to run for Congress.
Tell me about that decision.
I came to realize that there was a limit
to what I could do at the local level.
And so I had an epiphany
that if I want to become a
transformational policymaker,
if I want to have a systemic impact,
in improving life in public housing,
in breaking the cycle of
racially concentrated poverty.
Then I have to be in Washington DC
because that's where the rules are set.
And so I ran for Congress
and I ran in the most fiercely contested,
congressional primary in New York city.
I was one of 11 candidates.
The race included the
vice chair of the DNC,
the former speaker of the
New York city council,
a candidate endorsed by Bernie Sanders
and the most formidable opponent,
was a man by the name of Rubén Díaz Sr.
Who was known to be the most
anti LGBTQ elected official,
in New York State politics.
And for me, the triumph of
an openly LGBTQ candidate
is a powerful Testament,
to how far we've come as a society.
And I often point out,
who would have thought that
the first openly LGBTQ member
of the New York city
congressional delegation
would come not from
Chelsea, or the village,
or hell's kitchen but
from the South Bronx.
Another way Torres has
challenged expectations
as a Councilman and a Congressman,
is his willingness to engage
with New York City's business community.
It's a move, that in recent times,
carries significantly more risk
especially for a politician
embracing a progressive agenda.
He caught the attention of Kathy Wylde,
CEO of the partnership for New York City.
She represents some of the most powerful
and wealthy business
interests in New York.
I want to bring in one
more clip if we can.
I'm afraid to listen,
cause I know Kathy does
not stop for fools.
She does not, but I'm interested
to get your reaction to this, go ahead.
Yes, I met Ritchie early in
his tenure on the City Council
2014 when he first started
and he wasn't ideological
he hadn't stereotype business
as being the bad guys.
He was really open and interested.
He represents the poorest
congressional district
or certainly one of them in the country.
And yet he didn't see the wealthy,
the CEOs as being a negative force.
He was looking for them to
come into his community,
help with the development
of affordable housing.
Ritchie made it clear that government
does not have all the solutions
and there's hardly any political person
around these days, who
sees the world that way.
So yes, that's, he's courageous
and he's willing to stand up and say,
I'm going to be my own person.
So an interesting perspective
from someone who knows the
corridors of power, for sure.
Tell me about how you approach
what has become a hot button issue
which is, wealth and money in
this big city that we live in.
You know, as a city council member,
I'm willing to speak to Kathy,
I'm willing to speak to the
businesses that she represents,
in order to understand the industries
the government are regulating.
Does it mean that I'm
necessarily going to agree
on every issue?
No, but I feel it's important to
disagree without demonizing.
You know, there are those
who approach politics
with the fundamentalism of a religion.
Right, there were those
who essentially say,
"I alone have the absolute truth.
My policy prescriptions,
are the only path to salvation
and anyone who disagrees with me
is not simply wrong but evil
and should be burned at
the stake, for heresy."
You know, from my advantage point,
that kind of fundamentalism,
is incompatible with the
very nature of politics.
Which is about compromise
and coalition-building
and mutual understanding.
So I have to ask you and
as we start to wrap up here
about three Wednesdays,
your first three Wednesdays
as a member of Congress.
I don't even know where to
begin other than to say,
what were those three Wednesdays Like?
I refer to it as the
three wildest Wednesdays.
On January 6th, insurrection.
On January 13th impeachment.
And on January 20th inauguration.
This has been the most,
dramatic and draining
and disorienting month
for any freshmen class,
in the modern history
of the United States.
Do you solemnly swear
that you will support and defend
I suspect the freshman class,
that entered Congress during the civil war
had much more trauma than we did,
but by contemporary standards
of the drama that we've seen
in January is second to none.
Trump won!
The siege on the Capitol
was reminiscent of 9/11.
You know, I had the same sense of shock,
on January 6th that I had on 9/11.
Stop the steal!
I was in a state of
shock that a violent mob
would so willingly and could so easily
storm the Capitol and
invade the Senate Chamber
and terrorize members of
Congress and their staff.
Everybody stay down, get down!
You know and I have a number of colleagues
who are struggling with
post-traumatic stress,
in the wake of the siege.
And so as you settle in,
even with that as a backdrop.
How are you finding it? What is it like?
Covid is a challenge.
You know, Congress is a
collegial institution.
You're only as strong as
the relationships you build
because the goal is to leverage
those relationships in the
service of solving problems
and passing legislation,
and COVID-19 has hamstrung the ability
to build relationships.
So it's been eventful.
And do you look at the
district differently now?
What, how does it feel to you?
How does it look to you,
now that you are representing
it in Washington?
Representing these people
that you grew up among,
how do you think of yourself differently
I guess, now that you're in the seat?
As a member of Congress,
you know, I'm not simply a representative,
of the South Bronx.
I'm approaching issues that have,
implications for national security
and the international community.
You know, whether it's terrorism
or the SolarWinds hacking of government
and corporate networks.
These are issues that transcend
the provincial concerns
of a particular congressional district.
And it's important for me
as a member of Congress,
to be engaged on those issues,
to understand them deeply,
so that I can legislate thoughtfully.
But first and foremost,
I am a representative of the South Bronx.
You know, my mother has taught me
that the most important lesson,
is to never forget where you come from.
Never forget where your roots lie,
never forget the people
who voted you into office.
I want people to say, you know
my life is better for
having known Ritchie Torres.
If people say that,
then I know mine has
been a life well lived.